JAMIE KINNEY: Hi, everyone.
I'd like to welcome
you to INF300.
And thank you for
joining us today
for this Cloud Next session,
exploring GCE VM families.
Today, we're going to
start by giving you
an overview of the
GCE VM families.
And then we're going to
have a deep dive looking
at each of these VM families
to see how they're tailored
to meet the needs of
individual workloads,
looking at our
general-purpose VM
families, compute-intensive VM
families, memory-optimized VMs,
and then finally, options for
running accelerated workloads
on Google Compute Engine.
I'd like to start by
introducing myself.
I'm Jamie McKinney.
I'm a product manager.
And I am responsible for
the Tau T2D VM family.
I joined Google a little
bit over three years
ago initially as a cloud
solutions architect,
focusing on both scientific
and technical computing,
and also working with some
of Google Cloud's largest
customers as they migrated their
cloud-native workloads to GCE.
Subra, would you like
to introduce yourself?
SUBRA CHANDRAMOULI: Sure.
Thanks, Jamie.
Hey, my name is
Subra Chandramouli.
I'm also a product
manager at Google Cloud,
covering Google Compute
Engine products.
My background has been primarily
in the semiconductor industry,
focused on processors
and FPGA accelerators
for data center
markets, including--
amongst others.
JAMIE KINNEY: Thanks, Subra.
OK.
Just to kick things
off, I'd like
to start with an
overview of what GCE is.
So GCE, or Google
Compute Engine,
is Google Cloud's
managed service
for offering virtual
machines as a service.
With GCE, you can
easily choose a VM
that meets your needs,
either selecting
one of our predefined shapes
or custom-defining your own.
Following our recommendations,
if you'd like,
or if you have the
exact specifications,
you can dial in that VM to
precisely meet your needs.
GCE also takes care of a lot
of the operational overhead
of running applications,
offering technologies
like live migration,
for example, which
will allow us to easily
move your virtual machine
to a server while we perform
maintenance on a machine that
might need some assistance.
We can also give you
a number of mechanisms
to reduce the cost of running
your workloads when you run
on top of Google Compute
Engine with features
like sustained use discounts
that automatically provide
discounts for
long-running applications.
Or if you'd like to get
even deeper cost savings,
you can look at our one-year
and three-year committed use
discounts.
Today, our focus is going
to be on GCE VM families
and how to choose the right
family for the needs of a given
workload.
Just to provide a
little bit of history
on Google Compute Engine, we
initially launched the service
back in June of 2012.
And at that time,
Google Compute Engine
offered just a single
type of virtual machine.
And over the past nine years,
on top of that single VM family,
we also built a
number of features,
things like live
migration, the ability
to attach persistent
disk, and other features
that make those virtual machines
even more capable and powerful
and a better fit for your
applications and their needs.
In recent years, we've
expanded the number
of virtual machine families that
are offered by Google Compute
Engine to include
compute-optimized,
memory-optimized, accelerated
workload-optimized VMs,
and even more
general-purpose VM families.
So today, we're going
to look into each
of these young families and
see how they're best applied.
Starting with a map to
help you orient yourself
around the different VM
families that we offer,
we generally divide these into
two high-level categories,
general-purpose VMs and
workload-optimized VM families.
On the general purpose side,
we have the cost-optimized VM
families.
This includes E2.
And these are our VM
families that are designed
to minimize the price per vCPU.
We also offer a
balanced VM family
that gives you access to
all of GCE's features--
the flexibility to attach
local SSDs, to attach
any of our persistent
disk variants,
access to the
fastest networking,
and the ability to dial
in the custom VM shapes.
For customers that are
running scale-out workloads
for a wide range
of applications,
be it web serving
application serving
or even high-throughput
computing workloads,
we've introduced a new category
of VM families designed
to meet those needs, currently
including the Tau T2D VM
family that you'll be
hearing more from Subra.
On the other side
of this map, you
see the workload-optimized
VM families.
These are VM families
that are specifically
tailored to meet the needs
of a possibly niche or a very
well-defined set
of applications.
This could include the
compute-optimized VM
family that's really well suited
for high-performance computing,
game servers, and other
compute-intensive applications;
memory-optimized VMs for
vertically-scaled applications
that need access to
large amounts of memory
and balanced compute
to go with it;
and accelerator-optimized
VMs with TPUs and GPUs
to meet the needs
of machine learning
and other workloads that
benefit from these specific
accelerators.
In addition to VM families,
Google Compute Engine,
as I mentioned, over
the past several years
has developed a
number of features
that provide even more value to
your virtual machine engines.
This includes things like
custom machine types,
the ability to launch
sole-tenant VMs--
we'll talk about it more
later in the presentation--
the ability to attach
various forms of storage,
be it local SSD or persistent
disk storage of various speeds
and capabilities; and also
enhanced 100-gigabit networking
that delivers
fantastically low latency
and the bandwidth needed
for some of your most
demanding workloads.
Now I'd like to
hand it off to Subra
to give us a deeper dive on what
we mean by general-purpose VM
families and talk about the
workloads and the families that
tend to go with those.
Subra?
SUBRA CHANDRAMOULI:
Hey, thanks, Jamie.
As Jamie was alluding to,
one of our core philosophies
at Google Cloud is to enable
our customers the flexibility
to choose the right
virtual machine
to run their various
different workloads.
General-purpose workloads
make up a whole wide variety
from simple web serving, to
more complex media transcode
or processing types of
workloads, to data analytics,
to name a few.
You can also think of dev and
test as a separate workload
that--
whose requirements
are pretty unique.
In addition, various
enterprise applications
may be categorized under
the general purpose category
as well.
Our general-purpose N2
and N2D machine types
are a good fit for
such workloads.
Our general-purpose
N2 and N2D VMs
are designed to support
a variety of workloads
by offering a perfect balance
of compute and memory resources,
up to 224 vCPUs with
864 gigabytes of memory.
N2 and N2D machine types provide
a high degree of flexibility
for our customers.
Custom machine types enable you
to rightsize your resources,
enabling great cost
saving feature.
More on this later.
They also enable
you to auto-upgrade
to new CPU generations when
you launch a new CPU platform.
This means you can simply
choose a minimum CPU platform,
and Google will
automatically run your VM
on the latest-generation CPU.
And also attach up to 9
terabytes of local SSD
per node.
And you get high
networking performance up
to 100 gigabits per second.
These VMs are also available
globally across GCE regions
now.
The key difference
between N2 and N2D
are summarized in the table on
the right side of the slide.
N2 VMs are a general-purpose
Intel processor-based,
VMs supporting second-generation
Intel Xeon scalable
processor, or Cascade
Lake, and offering
VMs that go up to 80 vCPUs.
The N2 VMs offer
up to 20% to 30%
price performance
improvements compared to N1.
N2D is our AMD EPYC-based
general-purpose VMs
leveraging second-generation
AMD EPYC Rome processors.
They come with up to
224 vCPUs per node
and offer you a lower price
point, with approximately 13%
lower pricing compared
to our N2 machine types.
N2 VMs are ideal for
workloads that require
high per-core performance.
You can see some benchmarks that
compare N2 VMs to our N1 VMs
on the right side of the slide.
N2 machines are priced
at parity to N1 family,
enabling much higher
price performance when
compared to our N1 machines.
N2D machines are ideal for
high-throughput workloads
that can benefit from having
a large number of threads.
N2D machines are
ideal for workloads
that can benefit from
confidential computing
features in addition.
Switching gears a
bit, our E2 VM family
are ideal for applications
where cost is a priority.
E2 VMs offer machine
types up to 32 vCPUs
and 128 gigabytes of memory.
We also offer the flexibility
of choosing custom machine
types with our E2 family.
E2 family runs on Intel Haswell
through Cascade Lake and AMD
Rome processors.
E2 machines are ideal for dev
and test types of workloads
or for workloads that may be
batch-processed, for example.
This family provides up to
31% cost saving when compared
to our N1 family per VM.
Switching gears again,
earlier this year in June,
we announced our latest VM
family under the brand of Tau.
The T2D is our
first family of VMs
that will be offered
under the Tau brand.
Currently under
preview, Tau VMs are
designed to meet the
needs of customers
owning scale-out
workloads on Google Cloud.
We chose the Tau brand
as the Greek letter
tau is used to represent both
torque and the golden ratio.
The Torque is a
metaphor that is apt,
because T2D VM family allocates
an entire physical core
per vCPU, delivering excellent
per-thread performance,
while the golden
ratio tau represents
T2D's focus on only
core features needed
for scale-out workloads in
order to deliver excellent price
performance.
Focusing on T2D's
performance, we
can see that it outperforms
VM types available elsewhere.
Here's a quick look at
two benchmarks where
we showcase T2D's
price performance
for estimated
SPECrate and CoreMark.
For estimated SPECrate,
T2D provides 42%
better price performance when
compared to other major cloud
providers.
Back to you, Jamie.
JAMIE KINNEY: Thanks, Subra.
Now we'd like to take a look
at compute-intensive workloads.
And I thought we would
start by giving you
an overview of what we mean by
compute-intensive workloads.
While I've focused on scientific
and technical computing
in the past, compute-intensive
workloads actually
fall under a number of
verticals and industries
around the world.
This includes workloads such
as high-performance web servers
that need access to
fast clock speed CPUs,
as well as the networking
that allows pages to be served
with incredibly low latency.
Also really important
for triple-A game
servers that need to
both scale up vertically
but also ensure that
there's no jitter that's
being viewed as a result of any
inconsistencies in performance
with the CPU or
network variability.
High-performance computing,
near and dear to my heart,
tends to fall into two
categories-- tightly coupled,
which will usually
rely on low latency
networking between a
number of machines,
and also high-throughput
computing that
relies on many machines working
in concert to solve a problem,
where the per-core
performance of those machines
is going to indicate how
well that application runs.
And a great example of a
high-throughput computing
workload is Electronic
Design Automation, or EDA,
which needs access
to both fast cores,
but also a network that
makes it easy for all
of those cores to
access resources
that are stored on a
high-performance shared file
system.
In order to meet the needs
of these unique applications,
we've developed
compute-optimized VMs,
including the C2
family, that offer
a combination of excellent
per-core performance,
consistent performance,
and also isolation
between virtual machines.
The C2 VMs, as we can see here
with the benchmark results that
compare C2 to the
N1 family, offer
better per-core performance,
offer low latency,
high bandwidth
networking, and are really
designed to meet the needs
of these unique applications.
Another element of
the C2 family is
that the standard
machine types for C2
have a lower
memory-per-core ratio,
as these types of applications
tend to focus on CPU
needs as opposed
to taking advantage
of large amounts
of memory per core.
Speaking of memory
per core, I'd like
to now transition over to the
memory-intensive workloads.
So this could include a
number of different types
of applications.
It could be in-memory
database like SAP HANA.
analytics, OLAP systems,
and other analytic
systems that need
to keep data sets in memory
for low-latency analysis
and access, as well as
in-memory caching that's
common components
of many distributed
and cloud-native applications.
Think of Redis or
ElastiCache, for example.
For these workloads, the
M1 and M2 VM families
are likely to be your best fit.
M1 and M2 VMs can offer up
to 12 terabytes of memory,
while also offering a
large number of cores
to go hand-in-hand
with that memory
so that you're able
to analyze at scale.
The largest M2-- ultramem
and megamem VMs, for example,
offer over 400 cores or 400
vCPUs per virtual machine.
These VM families also take
advantage of the fully flexible
infrastructure, allowing you
to adjust the CPU and memory
needs provisioned to meet the
needs of your applications.
And we also support the
provisioning models,
including flex cuts,
that allow your--
to get discounts
when you're using
all of our memory-optimized
VM shapes, both current
and future.
Now I'd like to
transition us back
to another class of workloads.
These are the accelerated
workloads that
need access to GPUs and TPUs.
Subra, would you like
to give us an overview
of these workloads and the
VM families to go with them?
SUBRA CHANDRAMOULI: Sure.
Thanks, Jamie.
There are several workloads
that can take advantage
of hardware GPU acceleration.
Typically, these are
data-intensive workloads.
For instance, you may have
an AI inference or a training
type of a workload.
Some of the training
workloads could be bursty,
where they have to deal with a
lot of data in a bursty mode.
Or you can think
of a data analytics
where you have massive
data coming through,
and you have the ability to
process the data parallelly.
GPUs are a great fit
for parallel processing.
Other types of workloads
that can take advantage
of GPU acceleration are
high-performance computing
and several
video-intensive workloads.
Our A2 VM family
includes the latest
NVIDIA A100 GPUs with up
to 40 gigabytes of memory.
In these machine
types, we support up
to 96 vCPUs with 1.3
terabytes of memory.
These machines come in various
predefined machine types
with support up to
16 NVIDIA A100 GPUs,
delivering up to 10
teraflops of FP16 performance
or 20 teraflops of int8
performance in a single VM.
JAMIE KINNEY: Thanks, Subra.
Really appreciate that.
In addition to each of the VM
families that we've mentioned,
we also have a number
of GCE features
that span multiple VM
families and that are really
going to be relevant to a
broad range of workloads.
We just want to touch
on a few of these today.
And I'd like to start by talking
about custom machine types.
This is a feature that's
unique to Google Cloud.
And it's a feature that
is giving our customers
significant cost savings.
On average, they're
seeing 19% savings.
And in many cases,
they're seeing
substantially more than that.
Custom machine types, as you
can see in the little slide
or diagram in the
middle of this,
allows you to precisely dial
in the CPU and memory that's
allocated to the VMs that you're
launching within Google Compute
Engine.
This is often applied in cases
where the standard machine
types that we've predefined
for ease of use and flexibility
might not meet your
needs, and where
you need to allocate
perhaps a little bit
more memory or a little bit
more CPU for your workload.
And by allowing you to tell
us exactly what you need,
we don't over-provision
those resources for you.
This allows us to then reduce
the cost of Google Compute
Engine, and we pass those
savings back onto you.
Some additional
GCE features that
also benefit the wide
range of workloads
you might want to run
on Google Compute Engine
include sole-tenant nodes.
This is most often
applied for applications
that have licensing
requirements that
mandate that you are the
only customer, or only user,
running on a given
physical server.
The sole-tenant nodes, you have
access to the entire machine,
and you have the ability to
carve that up into whatever
VM shapes you need.
Very helpful for
applications that
have those specific
licensing requirements.
Shielded VMs are a
feature that allow
you to ensure that
your workloads are
running on trusted
and verified hardware,
taking advantage of
the TPM UEFI firmware
that we're running on
GCE infrastructure.
And confidential VMs
provide additional isolation
and sandboxing for especially
sensitive applications.
You can read more
about these in some
of the resources that we've
provided below, accessing both
the GCE documentation
tutorials, case
studies, and other resources.
We've also provided some links
to additional Next sessions
that you might want
to attend, as well as
a couple of Coursera
courses for those of you
who might be new to
Google Compute Engine
or simply want to expand your
familiarity and understanding
of our services.
With that, I'd really
like to thank Subra
for joining me today.
And most importantly, I'd like
to thank you for joining us
and for listening to this talk.
I hope that it improves your
understanding of Google Compute
Engine.
And I hope that the rest
of your Next experience
is a wonderful one.
Have a great day.
Thanks.